et on parle du complément d'enquête de
ce soir qui m consacré est-ce que je
zape est-ce que je matate et ce qui est
fou c'est que les équipes de complément
d'enquête m'avaient déjà suivi en 2009
mais pas pour fracasser parce que
j'étais à France Télévision j' animé un
jeu la porte ouverte à toutes les
fenêtres par
par présentateur c'est un humoriste et
un animateur qui a fait ses armes sur
une petite chaîne du
câble C Hanouna c'est l'équipe de
d'quête France je regarde souvent cette
comment ça va ma chérie oui ça va bien
les questionsut-être pendant que tu te
fais maquill attaque 10 minutes avant
l'antenne Cyr et Michell passent en
revue toutes les questions à poser au
candidat
d'accord par voilà zo BO est-il un chef
d'État africain ou le fils de David B à
votre avis la question elle un quiz
prétexte à la
rigolade j'adore être avec les candidats
moi donc voilà donc j'ai des candidats
et en plus j'ai et mes potes qui sont
dans les dans les fenêtres donc là c'est
vrai que c'est c'est formidable e ouais
e ouais e ouais c'est fort
ça j'avais des tepins mon frère vous
avez
glopé non mais j'avais des tepin mon
frère c'était mais c'était Elvis mon
frère c'est quoi ça alors tu vas
regarder GG ah oui bah oui oui oui parce
que déjà effectivement on l'a tous dit
ici il y a une sorte d'adrénaline
d'électricité et donc moi j'aime bien
quand regarder ensemble ta ch ah oui bah
oui j'tait pas au courant bah non ah je
te le dis tu vas regarder EMB ok voilà
bon ben ok
euh et donc du coup non non j'ai du coup
oui bon ben alors ok et
non donc ouais non en revanche non moi
il y a un truc qui m'a il y a un truc
voilà il y a un truc qui m'a fait
vraiment de la peine mais vraiment de la
peine dans tout ce que j'ai vu là de ce
qu'il a dit la Tristant ce matin et tout
ça quand il dit qu'on est des ventriloes
et quand on dit qu'on est sur commande
en fait moi ça m'a moi ça m'a fait de la
peine je me suis mais qui m'appelle en
fait mais mais c'est insupportable
c'està dire qu'en fait pour nous mais en
fait mais non pas du tout c'est
humiliant non mais moi je trouve ça
humiliant sais ce que tu veux tu sais
que tu dis ce que tu mais je trouve que
c'est min parce que c'est un mensonge
absolu parce que apparemment il aurait
trouvé des SMS où il y avait un sujet
sur la peine de mort où je vous disais
il y a quelqu'un l'assistante vous disz
qui plus qui apparemment est plus là je
sais pas qui c'est qui envoyé ça oui
Cyril voudrait deux personnes qui disent
oui pour la peine de mort je sais même
pas d'où ils ont trouvé je suis même pas
sûr quand on avit fait ce non mais s'il
y a des abrutis qui sont d'accord pour
changer d'avis mais globalement
humiliant parce par qu'en fait on dit
toujours s'il y a un je sais pas on peut
éventuellement tout vous reprocher je
n'en sais rien j'ai pas vu le
documentaire mais en revanche dire que
nous on dit ce que vous voulez entendre
par rapport à ce que vous voulez
entendre je trouve que c'est d'une
malhonnêteté intellectuelle et
journalistique mais absolu vous
inquiétez pas on Vauper de ça non mais
voilà j'ai trouvé ça dégueulasse quoi
voilà j'aime j'aime pas ce procéd parce
que c'est tellement mensongé après c'est
repris partout je l'ai entendu au GG je
l'ai entendu chez Stelle genre on est
voilà on est des on est des bén oui oui
en fait on nous dit de dire ce qu'on a
dire mais quand on prend le torrent ce
que Gill se prend ce qu'on se prend nous
CEPR Val et tout ça mais en fait c'est
débile en fait on n'est pas on n'est pas
à la botte de ce que vous voulez qu'on
dise en fait c'est juste insupportable
et moi ça m'a vraiment énervé vous êtes
embrouillé tous les deux avec une
histoire de vaccin Béatrice elle est
venue ici elle elle a donné son avis
tout le monde a donné son avis non mais
ça on s'en fout rentrez pas
làdedans dis toujours si vous rentrez
sur chaque truc sachez-le on s'en fout
faut laisser c'est des journalistes ou
c'est pas des journalistes vérité vérit
Mo je vous dis que c'est pas des
jour public ça veut dire qu'on dit au
public qu'on est je veux dire on a le
droit de pas aimer l'émission mais qu'on
nous dise pas que nous on est des
marionnettes et qu'on est des pentins et
que derrière on a une oreillette qui dit
quoi dire ou mais audelà de notre cas
personnel nous on sait que ça c'est faux
donc ça pose question sur les autres
compléments d'enquête pardon mais si'
manque làdessus nous sa pertinment c'est
fa tous les complément
d'enquêtez il y a plein de trucs faux
c'est normal qu'il a des trucs faux
comme ça non mais non alors moi je vais
te dire je pense je l'ai pas vu j'ai
fait j'ai réag j'ai réagi à à ça
justement à ce qu'il a dit à télétin ils
ont fait plein de boss qui savent faire
à écrire mon expérience c'estàd que moi
j'ai dit parce que j'imagine bien que
s'il le dit c'est qu'il a un exemple et
tout le problème est là c'est là où
c'est la Manon ce que j'appelle moi de
la manonéé journalistique pourquoi parce
que il y a un événement mais est-ce que
cet événement est représentatif de ce
que tu fais d'habitude si tu as j'en
sais rien moi tu es combien d'émissions
100000 200000 émissions si tu as un cas
d'un mec qui a dit un jour ouais bon ok
je vais dire ça pour équilibrer le
plateau je sais pas quoi je sais pas ce
qu'il y a ce soir dans dans dans ce
j'imagine que s'il le dit c'est qu'il y
a a un
cascis et je pense que toute la
construction pour faire Simp je pense
que toute la construction du magazine
est comme ça c'est que je pense que à
chaque fois il y a un petit truc et que
de ce petit truc on va extrapoler et
dire que c'est la règle générale sur ta
façon de faire ta façon de penser et
cetera après on verra mais bon moi je
pense que c'est une forme de
malhonnêteté journalistique et
intellectuelle moi c'est quelque chose
que j'approuve pas quoi voilà dans les
grandes ce matin vous les avez cité
comprennent pas pourquoi service public
se met à faire des enquêtes à charge sur
des animateurs de chaîne concurrente
regardez ils n'ont pas trouvé
grand-chose c'est comme si en fait on
était parti sur une entreprise de
démolition tu vois il fallait absolument
trouver de quoi démolir cy Cyril Hanouna
sur le vertueux service public et
complément d'enquête je me est-ce que
c'est la mission d'une d'une émission
d'investigation sur service public parce
que en plus on va chercher finalement
l'animateur de la concurrence on
pourrait se dire tiens d'enquête
pourquoi pas Nagi tu vois Nagi qui a
batti une fortune sur le service public
qui est producteur qui est animateur
peut-être aussi il y a des choses à dire
sur Nagi mais moi je voilà c'est c'est
un peu le truc qui me dérange si c'est
pas pour analyser le phénomène à Nouna
mais uniquement chercher à nous
démontrer qu'il est pas sympa que ses
collaborateur qui les humilie bah
bon vous sa le problème de cette
émission c'est qu'elle a été préparée à
l'envers ils ont pas dit regardez on a
un truc sur cyil Alouna on va faire un
documentaire ils ont dit on va défoncer
Cyril hanuna qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir
c'est là tout le problème bravo tu dis
bravo viment bravo mais c'est ça
journalistiquement c'est l'inverse de ce
qu'il faut faireis dire merci moi au
grand gueules qui ont été fabuleux et
particulièrement t toutes les grandes
gueules qui vraiment j'ai trouvé qu'il
étaient été formidable et
particulièrement à mourade bien bal qui
est un franchement un mec qui a fait une
énorme réussite mourade et qui a eu des
mots qui m'ont énormément touché je le
dis et Mourad tu sais comme je t'estime
et ça m'a encore énormément touché ce
que tu as dit ce matin et je vrais dire
aussi Daniel Riolo chez Esther chez
Estelle Denis qui a étit
formidable bien plus que Thierry Morau
qui était avec nous et qui nous met des
des tacle partout mais on fera les
comptes au bon moment Thierry Mau je
vais m'en occuper oui merci j'aime bien
leur débat et leur interrogation sur
est-ce que ce serait pas déceptif parce
que finalement ils n'ont pas trouvé
assez et ça ça ça a l'air d'être une
tendance qui émerge un peu aujourd'hui
et et ça c'est quand même ultra bizarre
quoi c'estàdire que journalistiquement
on on on veut aller très à char
ont un gros truc c'est apparemment le
Yach donc on vous a fait une compile sur
cette histoire de yaach de bateau ils
sont comme des fous bah je les inviterai
cet été comme ça ils seront contents ils
iront nager 2 secondes et puis on les
laissera à l'eau allez c'est parti merci
alors on découvre que cyil Anouna a un
Yach un Yach Lamborghini de 3 millions
d'euros donc voilà on savait que cy
anuna gagnait très bien sa
vie bah oui de la rue laiss finir Benoît
allez-y benoî ouais donc voilà ça on
découvre on découvre on découvre qu'il
est pas que il n'est pas sous pavillon
français qu'il est sous pavillon
britannique donc donc vois il y a un
petit montage fin prier faire de
l'optimisation voilà c'est pas c'est pas
illégal hein surtout qui dépense son
pognon en faisant de l'optimisation
fiscale ben il a bien raison il a bien
raison parce qu'il est ni le premier ni
le dernier en faire on peut pas lui
reprocher moi je trouve ce qui me gêne
le plus moi c'est c'est pas il a un
bateau enfin c'est comme cétait
aujourd'hui que les riches avaient des
bateaux des machins enfin un moment
donné il y a rien de c'est c'est comme
ça c'est le monde actuel il est comme ça
et je trouve qu'ils ont tous été
intéressants même ceux qui étaient
contre moi je les ai trouvé très
intéressant dans les grandes gueules et
alors
ag journe rais de dire c'est tout àit
légal et tout Lee fait voilà donc
aucunme en fait ils on essayé de
chercher des trucs mais à chaque fois il
arriv et ils arrivaient sur des pics
donc vous allez voir ce soir puis il y a
le choix de Booba dans les fauteuils
rouges sachez que Booba je l'ai vu deux
fois dans ma vie ici j'ai jamais vu en
dehors il est venu ici deux fois Booba
pas grand monde na compris regardez et
c'est Booba qui sert de témoin de
moralité alors c'est Booba une interview
qui a été enregistré en Floride mais
c'est boa qui est un des désormais un
des PIR et demi de Cyril Hanouna qui est
très fâché notamment au niveau de des
relations entre Cyril Hanouna et les
influenceurs et du coup voilà je pense
que que Booba évidemment il va il va il
va dénoncer fortement le les
comportements de CA et Booba qui va
dénoncer les comportements de je le
connais absolument pas boa je l'ai vu
deux fois ici et Booba je pense que il y
a une Darca dans l'interview c'est qu'il
se rend compte qu'en fait son patron
c'est Vincent Bori et il y a tristanex
qui lui montre qui lui dit vous avez vu
que vous avez un point commun avec voit
une photo avec lui ah et il dit ah ben
oui c'est mon patron chez Universal et
là je vois dans la tête de je vois que
tout s fond il se dit mais pourquoi je
suis venu pourquoi j'ai fait ça oui Bou
on a le même patron Vincent Boloré oui
oui oui et donc il dit il dit voilà il
dit il dit bah il faut qu'il vire
Morandini Pascal pro et cyil Hanouna
écoute bon ben on va voir les décisions
que va prendre notre grand patron dans
les prochains jours je sais pas oui
c'est triste parce que ça veut bien dire
que on est dans une démarche politique
on de buz de buzz de buz
mais à mon avis plus
généralementque pour le groupe France
Télévision aujourd'hui et ce que vient
de dire Guillaum est absolument
essentiel c'est la base du journalisme
il faut que tout le monde le comprenne
on part sur une enquête parce qu'on
découvre queil y a une malversation on
part sur une enquête parce qu'on
s'aperçoit qu'il a un problème quand tu
veux faire rentrer dans une enqu oui
mais quand tu décides en fait de faire
les choses à l'envers et de dire tiens
je vais prendre C Hanouna parce que je
vais faire de l'audience et puis parce
que mes patrons vont être contents parce
que comme ça on va bien défoncer
quelqu'un du du groupe Boloré parce
qu'on les a dans le pif et que c'est pas
la télé qu'on veut défendre ce qui est
un problème en soi parce que c'est pas
le rôle du service public je regette et
bien à partir de momentl tu inverses les
choses je vais vous dire ce que je pense
on est en train de préparer un enquête
complémentaire sur les méthodes de
complément d'enquête et sur France
Télévision et le problème et je le dis à
France Télévision c'est que ils auraient
pas dû parce que je pense qu'ils ont
fait une enquête qui est un petit peu
baclé et où il y a rien dedans et mine
de rien je peux vous dire vous pouvez
chercher he sur moi chercher moi j'ai
pas de compte voilà j'ai pas de compte
caché moi je je voilà je fais tout tout
bien moi je fais tout tout dans les
règles donc les gars pouvez chercher
d'ailleurs ils ont cherché de toute
façon ça fait ça fait quoi an qu'il
cherch il av ils auraient trouvé rien
mais le problème c'est que nous on a
déjà commencé à chercher sur complément
d'enquête et sur france télé et on n pas
mis longtemps à trouver et quand ça va
tomber ça va être plus compliqué je
pense que ce qui va se passer pour nous
ce soir nous ce soir on sera
tranquillement en train de manger des
frit cassés et des mini pizzas et en
train de rigoler je pense que dans un
mois quand on va sortir le complément
d'enquête sur complément d'enquête et
sur France
Télévision j'ai
peur ça tremble un petit peu dans la
Tour de France Télé les chérriis et je
peux vous dire qu'on a nous pour le coup
du très très lourd sachez-le quand je
vous dis du très très lourd c'est du
très très lourd et c'est pas des des
témoins masqués alors parce qu'ils ont
fait un truc de fou il y a un ancien
chroniqueur qui a parlé voilà je vous le
dis je sais pas qui sa mais bon voilà et
ils ont pas pris le gars en sil
ils ont pas pris la voix du gars ils ont
mis un comédien qui fait le gars avec
une autre voix et soustitré donc c'est
leur gros témoin et c'est leur gros
témoin du
truc mais ça ils disent non ancien
collaborateur mais c'est en fait un
ancien chroniqueur mais c'est pas on
sait même pas qui c'est le gars voilà et
donc le gars c'est genre il dit des
trucs que j'aurais dit moi mais c'est un
comédien qui est soustitré parce qu'il
voulait juste ni la voix ni le truc et
il y a une silhouette d'un gars qu's ont
pris nimp ils ont dû prendre un gars
dans les couloirs viens de minutes
Jean-Louis tu fais silhouette c'est des
Peru donc voilà donc c'est c'est risible
à souer je vous jure moi ce soir je
l'attends comme une consécration et
comme une Darca exceptionnelle il y en a
un qui a dit qui a donné son avis sur le
documentaire de soir c'est Daniel Riolo
qui a été exceptionnel chez Estelle
regardez je connais quand même bien
l'émission euh toi aussi tu as bossé à
H8 donc bon écoute on verra bien si on
apprend des choses j'ai pas l'impression
au vu de ce que j'entends que ça va être
révolutionnaire par rapport à ce qui
était annoncé au début parce que ça se
voulait au début comme quelque chose qui
allait faire tomber la statue euh au
final c'est pas du tout ce qui va se
passer quand on me dit qu'on a fait
autant d'enquêtes aussi longtemps un an
d'enquête pour arriver à ça bah je me
dis qu'elle a pas super bien travaillé
et si en plus derrière on me dit qu'elle
a eu des pressions bon alors c'est soit
il y a pas eu tant de pression que ça
soit Thierry Morau est un héros et un
résistant des temps modernes parce que
lui il a réussi à parler euh et les
autres ont eu peur de parler écoute on
verra bien on verra le résultat Thierry
Morau un résistant des temps modernes
c'est la meilleure V de Daniel Riolo
bravo Daniel en tout cas qui m'a bien
bien bien fait rire Daniel Morau qui va
qui va regarder qui je pense
fondamentalement Cyril c'est que je suis
persuadé que il y a une sorte de
fantasme elle a dit Virginie Villard
elle
aelle
dire elle a a eu plein de fauses pistes
on enquêtait partout il y avait plein de
fauses pistes et à la fin on s'est rendu
compte qu'on avait pasien grandchose
elle arrête pas de dire on n pas voulu
faire un un un témoignage un
documentaire à charge parce que du coup
maintenant tu vois bien dans la
communication que ah mais non n'a pas
voulu être à charge on veut juste
raconter le parrain du PAF sa puissance
et cetera et cetera ça ça veut dire que
tu trouves pas moi j'ai une autre info
c'est que ça fait plusieurs semaines que
quelques personnes qui l'ont vu alors le
doc il a été très très caché il y avait
très peu de gens qui pouvaient le voir
mais il regrette y compris au niveau de
la direction de l'info de pas avoir ce
qu'on appelle le smoking gun c'estàd que
le petit truc qui fait que ça bascule et
que tu te dis ah ça on l'avait pas quoi
voilà ça on le savait pas tout
simplement parce qu'il y avait pas voilà
moi je pense c'est très très bien ce que
dit euh ton amis tout à l'heure c'est
top mais Daniel pardon mais mais je
pense que c'est une très bonne
journaliste et c'est pas qu'elle a pas
bien travaillé c'est que ils l'ont ils
l'ont essoré pendant 8 mois 10 mois elle
est très bonne mais elle a pas trouvé
parce qu'il y a pas à trouver et c'est
là où est toute l'erreur journalisti
quand on m'a dit on va faire un
complément d'enquête sur je me suis dit
ou ils vont inventer des trucs oui ou
bien je vais te dire ça va être
compliqué donc ils ont inventé quelques
trucs comme quoi je vous dis de faire si
de faire ça et ils ont fait et ils ont
un gros truc aussi sur la bravem vous
savez quoi comme quoi les policiers de
la Braem é ven on avit annoncé c'est des
policiers de la bravem et d'ailleurs je
dis on reçoit quatre policiers de la
bravem et il y a le gars qui me dit tout
de suite non non on est pas quatre de la
bravem il y en a qu'un de la bravem et
d'ailleurs je suis en contact avec lui
qui m a même dit lui que c'était une
erreur de de de l'équipe voilà voilà qui
m'avait dit que c'était des mecs de la
bravem et moi voilà je vous dis la
vérité j'étais arrivé j'ai dit quatre de
la bravem et en fait ils étaient qu'un
de la bravem pour vous dire le truc le
gros truc de ce soir c'est ça il doit
avoir quatre mecs de la bravem il en a
eu qu'un ce qu'on sait dernière info
majeur c'est tu vas battre un record
d'audience ce soir j'en suis persuadé je
pense que c'est pas complément d'enquête
qui va gagner c'est toi qui va gagner en
fait je gagne toujours à la fin moià et
le deuxième record c'est que il faut
quand même le dire parce que c'est
important un complément d'enquête c'est
entre 100 et 150000 € de dépenses là on
est plutôt entre 240 et 270 pourquoi
Miami ça coû cher non c'est pas ça mais
moi j'ai fait tout le calcul je le
publierai on va en parler demain de ça
t'inquiète pas on fera tout le détail
demain je sais que vous adorez ça et
demain on vous fera l'addition merci
c'est vous qui payer les chéris en plus
donc merci oui et il y a une autre
erreur monumentale qu'ils ont commise à
mon sens c'est que il ils l'ont annoncé
un an avant mais qui fait ça même
journalistiquement là encore ils
auraient dû peut-être commencer à
travailler dessus et s'ils se rendent
compte qu'il y a pas grandchose ne pas
le faire mais une fois que tu l'as
annoncé tu es dans la merde tu es obligé
de sortir une émission et l'annonce même
ENF moi j'ai jamais vu un autre
complément d'enquête annoncé un an avant
et ça montre bien que c'est une
entreprise de déstabilisation contre
vous al ou mais c'est c'est peut-être un
peu l'ego du présentateur alors je vais
vous dire il y a Christine qui m'écrit
Christine Bravo que j'adore j'ai été
viré de France 2 car je n'acceptais pas
le Billboard magouille du directeur des
programmes avec son pote publicitaire
pour avoir dit non j'ai perdu mon
émission tu peux me citer rien à
c'est des merdes elle sera dans enquête
complémentaire et ça c'est grave ça
parce que vous rendez compte ce qu'elle
vient de dire là chrise bravo ça veut
dire que vousexplique l'histoire là
parce que là déjà rien qu'avec ça les
gars c'est rideau voilà merci on arrête
tout merci au revoir je vous explique
l'histoire que vient de nous dire
Christine France 2 c'est magouille grave
et c'est vrai qu'elle a raison vous
allez voir notre enquête complémentaire
c'est catastrophique c'estàdire que ils
ont voulu nous attaquer avec un couteau
suisse les gars on va arriver à la
sulfateuse je vous le dire regardez on a
des témoignages tout le temps Christine
Bravo si elle veut être dans l'enquête
de complément qu'est-ce qu'elle veut
dire la Christine Bravo rendez compte de
l'histoire c'estàdire qu'il y avait le
directeur des programmes ce qu'elle est
en train de dire Christine Bravo je mets
ça bien sûr au conditionnel hein elle
dit qu'en fait elle a été virée parce
que le directeur des programmes
apparemment vous savez il y a toujours
des marqu avant les émissions genre TPMP
avec avec un tel inel et donc il prenait
un petit billet sur le le le Billboard
ce qu'on appelle le Billboard le truc
qui annonce l'émission vous rendez
compte ou pas de ça ça déjà rien que
çaéresse merci les gars merci on ferme
quand terminé je peux vous dire ce que
je peux dire juste à France Télévision
prépareer juste un rideau euh parce que
à mon avis appeler un rideau métallique
parce que je pense que ça va être la
catastrophe dans moins d'un mois voilà
merci en tout cas euh on va en parler
bien sûr demain de ça